[Music]
so in peace out YouTube news no your
boom submitted by ah true that's what
YouTube and Facebook are losing creators
to black chain powered rivals what if
they are losing creators I don't know
which ones who are the blockchain rivals
there's this really popular one right
now called D tube like dick tube they -
so the porns like furious Pete and
hodgetwins are already on it you know
well I'm asking what's up with this D
tube stuff they gave him some money a
lot of new platforms sprouting now to
compete with YouTube and Facebook
especially now that creators are unhappy
with the censorship in order to remain
advertiser friendly algorithm issues
with YouTube and privacy issues with
Facebook but the whole data scandal that
just happened called a message and then
like all major platforms are blocking of
crypto advertising and so that's like a
lot of the reasons why people are moving
to these new platforms they don't
advertise crypto things on YouTube no
their YouTube and Facebook are children
and it's shielding themselves from legal
liability Wow cuz you know for the
longest time
I would see this pre-roll of this guy
like in the Bahamas showing people their
[ __ ] Bitcoin amount and I was like
what the [ __ ] well you probably won't
see that anymore cuz there's no more huh
so we're gonna talk mainly about g-tube
here so they're saying that it's the
first crypto decentralized video
platform built on top of the steam
blockchain and ipfs peer-to-peer network
hmm I don't know I mean I know it means
but I'll just keep it in here until I
hear it again oh it sounds familiar
no I'm ago now so I can be the tap yeah
yeah so these creators are relying on
digital coins instead of Adsense so it's
kind of like a patreon type of thing
where we're paying you to create your
content yeah or like donating donating
and so there's no censorship on these
type of platforms because since it's
peer-to-peer there's no one like
controlling everything and like
censoring things or Wow yeah there's not
a guideline being enforced like oh is it
a website that you can kind of that'll
host your stuff that's what it seems
like yeah it's like based off of
decentralized it's a decentralized video
platform did you check out D tube comm
is that where it is or it's uh yeah yeah
that sounds so crazy it sounds so next
level they don't even know what to make
of it cuz I I have this idea so it's
like porn right but it's also movie but
like so imagine a movie a normal movie
but instead of cutting away during the
sex scene it's a porno so you get real
sick the best of both worlds so it's
like a French movie yeah but you see
penetration yeah French movies yeah all
you see the [ __ ] pop ha ha yeah you
see that going there's a film called 9
songs that has actual penetration like
everything by gonna do no [ __ ] artsy
ass Frenchie [ __ ] I'm gonna be like
Marvel [ __ ] and then like you know why
would you [ __ ] close out the scene
when they kiss and it just say just like
you to wonder woman like where they had
that moment she sees how awesome he is
before he flies in the plane she [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of him yep so I like your
idea and and not for this idea , pay for
right now see it's a genius [ __ ] idea
but I don't know what it has to do with
what's going on in this article well
because the content that I'm gonna be
creating no censorship and it's gonna be
funded by people like you and Bart
that's what I'm talking about yeah so
it's DDOT tube there's no calm oh it's
DDOT - looks like YouTube like YouTube
this is a Chinese company right they
called everything exactly like you - so
they just switched you its YouTube into
it
and then they just added this basically
it's just YouTube's new blockchain
crypto initiative that'd be smart
they're saying that their data is public
and so anyone with the internet
connection could just look at all the
data that YouTube has I was called a
catch dope and so there's this one
creator that she says that she makes
about forty dollars per video in digital
coins when it would take months for her
to do that on YouTube so it's like she's
already making more money on t-tube bag
thank you
yeah and then still need a lot of videos
to make a living though the downside
here though is that you have to convert
it convert these coins into Bitcoin and
then into dolls mmm
yeah and then they're saying that like
people are the ones that control what
hmm I'm just shaking my head at D to
like explain that so much work yeah like
it's a lot of work and I mean maybe they
picked the worst person interview but
I'm 40 now is left with every video yeah
I want to hear someone that's like I
used to make a hundred thousand of video
on YouTube but now I make a million of
video or some [ __ ] I don't know bigger
numbers sometimes it cost like $200 to
make a video if she's only making 40
bucks just losing $160 of the video
sounds like a David so comedy video to
me it takes $200 to make your video and
you make 40 bucks yeah I think is who
I'd like a side thing like it's like me
I have a lot of the videos that YouTube
wouldn't monetize now so if I put all of
those Oh genius well I do regular [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah so you get your fan base on
YouTube and you say to see my dick go to
deep dick a good chunk of the videos
think he's producing are being posted on
d2 but he's still also posting his
regular showing that's genius so I'll
have like the Marvel movie on YouTube
and then I'll have a little [ __ ] it well
you can't do annotations anymore but
it's like if you guys want to check out
the full six so you go to tube but the
only problem with that
is when everybody gets on it
think about how you know I'm saying how
many people you're subscribed to on
YouTube you're gonna pay all of those
[ __ ] to watch this [ __ ] so
you've got to jump on it early and make
some amazing [ __ ] to keep getting that's
like twitch right now a lot of people's
getting paid direct yeah well like
patreon I don't do it I don't do any of
those things I should though I just feel
weird like getting money without giving
them anything for it yeah that was the
saying that um the creativity on these
platforms seem to be pretty low it's
like they're just posting videos just to
make money like it's all money moves
everyone makes going on there it's a
money move no one's really going on
there because of the creativity yeah but
somebody will and they're gonna blow the
[ __ ] up yeah and then everybody else
will so whatever that first person is
you can't start a platform based on
money and expect people to be creative
exactly like the way they're selling it
is we're not gonna do the algorithms out
there it's peer to peer like everything
you're selling to me I'm like okay it
just sounds like money but if they were
like we got the greatest tools for you
to edit we're gonna give you a bunch of
like different laugh tracks you're
[ __ ] you know uncopyrighted music
then I'm like okay they want to please
but here's the thing
everybody knows monetization exists
who's gonna say I'm gonna get on this
new site where there's no money yeah
well that's what it is it's like for
YouTube and because it was the first of
its kind and it was based on creativity
yeah I mean then obviously disappeared a
lot but it still has glimpses of
creativity where people just don't give
a [ __ ] and they create some of the best
content yeah you know but that it's
already starting off on a bad foot I
mean some of one site where you I don't
even think to monetize that all and has
some of the most creative videos is
Vimeo and it's just because they don't
compress the video yeah so people that
are hella into video quality they go if
I make this video I put it on this site
I know it's not gonna get [ __ ] up but
because there's no money attached at all
and it's just all about the highest
quality video you have some of the best
videos online on Vimeo I always go to
Vimeo so I could just lower my
self-esteem I don't even go on Vimeo to
search as I should though that should
hurts my foot I think I use YouTube to
watch reuploaded episodes of History
Channel documentaries yeah mostly
illegal content
it's like another downside to this that
they're saying is that like the freedom
that is gained by these platforms but no
one controlling any stuff then there are
more undesirable material on speech and
scam yeah people show that reason yeah
[ __ ] on animals and there's also
fundamental issues with these platforms
like the fact that they're not super
reliable there's a lot of bugs lags
glitches and it seems like BOTS are the
best way to get your content notice so
you kind of have to like play to win
type of thing so it sounds like the same
problem lower again yeah and if it's
just like that free and open and
nobody's really watching over it's gonna
get hacked like a [ __ ] and I'm
okay caught that yeah yeah and YouTube
takes 25% of your earning 25 that's
better than YouTube they take 50% yeah
but you don't know what you give before
you do I'll show you I'll show you how
you it's it's in there and you get paid
way more I'd rather get paid way more
take 40% or 50% than to get paid nothing
and then take 25% nothing else see
channels like this thank you like news
like just getting this films yeah I'm
just kidding to use just kidding phones
and all that and like we always now we
kind of have to tiptoe around things
that weird the way we title things
because of the demonic abuse that sucks
and like I don't know seeing how this is
kind of starting to pop off do you see
JK moving to a site like this I think it
depends because I don't know if our
entire audience will move you know like
we'll bring some but then also I don't
like I'm not an early adopter when it
comes to things like this like I would
test it but I think it'll be too abrupt
because like it's not a it's not as big
as like if it was like twitch yeah then
it's like oh [ __ ] there's an audience
right but then like there's so many
people still on YouTube yeah we tried
Bethel and that didn't really yeah I
don't think it was a lot of them there
wasn't that many you know I was going I
don't appreciate like the whole title
thing is [ __ ] annoying
I think that you should allow people to
have whatever tile that they have as
long as the content is what it's about
like I had a title that simply stated
what this compass
we talked about what come taste like
that the perks personally I think that
was the problem for what for Trojan
condoms exactly that's that's what
bugged me they're not doing a good job
they're not a good good job of selling
the content but I also think the
problems that we're facing they're
actually not that bad it does [ __ ] with
a lot of people's businesses but it's
actually not that bad and I think with
more restrictions and more control
that's where the most creative [ __ ]
actually comes out so you need control
you need parameters to be creative you
give people open canvas draw whatever
you want and they're not gonna draw
anything at all well we're the one go
ahead but if you're like hey draw this
frog but I also want this frog to be
able to like fly a plane then all of a
sudden some guys gonna draw some amazing
[ __ ] so in order to be creative you need
rules you need restrictions so I just
think it's just up to the creator's to
be able to be extra creative and step
above above it well we're not as hurt as
the gun industry or people that are
doing financial like videos on crypto
and all that stuff or sex advice and
stuff like that because you can't even
put anything in the title that's
remotely close to even if it's
educational here yeah
so those I think those those businesses
are hurt the most out of anything you
know we're just a talk show we could
kind of Bend around it you know but a
lot of people's entire channels and
careers and they're not even doing
anything Shady
we're not compared to like some of these
channels that should be demonetized
completely you know but they bring in so
many views that YouTube just lets them
keep it yeah I personally hate how
they're just [ __ ] with the whole
algorithm thing like people that are
subscribed and they they had the bell
for notifications like they still won't
get notified when a new video is up like
what's up with that I mean for the
longest time they've been denying it too
and I was like I know something's up
Matthew cuz it doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense every video someone's like hey I
haven't been notified for the last three
videos that you uploaded or like I had
to resub to you but I'm not getting
videos and it's like what the [ __ ]
YouTube why are they doing that like
why good yeah porky cuz I never
complained to you or I never felt like
hey man
all these [ __ ] channels that I
subscribe to are blowing up my feed
YouTube I would unsubscribe to them yeah
unclick the Bell exactly but then what
the [ __ ] dude like they want to choose
who's worthy within your subscription -
it's like what the [ __ ] yeah there's a
couple of [ __ ] cooking shows I'm
subscribed I don't see any of their [ __ ]
yeah I have to go to their channel
that's annoying
[Music]
[Music]